as droves of people fleeing conflict
continued arrive in their thousands kid
new fans of Assyria and Africa along
with a strengthened partnership of
Turkey helped turn the tide against a
migration phenomenon is time to find out
welcome to the agenda EU leaders warned
that there are no quick fixes the kid
the migrant crisis really last a
generation at the mini plenary in
Brussels MEP s will vote on a finance
package for Africa worth one point eight
billion years and for Syria half a
billion euros to help tackle the root
causes of migration along with providing
humanitarian aid to refugees it's seen
as a gateway to Europe a transit
destination for refugees so can Turkey
be convinced to shore up its porous
border over two million refugees have
been hosted in Turkey already Matthias
arruda the European Commission's
director-general for migration and Home
Affairs will be at the Parliament to
debate a closer partnership with Turkey
and help to stem the flow of migrants
bout for Europe the first few families
have now been relocated from Greece to
Luxembourg but Greece still needs a lot
more help 600,000 people have inundated
Greece but as prime minister says his
country is willing to house tens of
thousands more a hearing is planned on
Tuesday and will be attended by the
Eurogroup President Gerald I saw bloom
to look at financially support increased
better one word fitsum candidate the
2014 European elections were different
because for the first time they help
choose the President of the European
Commission but could the election
process be improved ideas being put
forward include postal electronic voting
and allowing EU citizens living outside
the EU to cast a vote to is an energy
union just a pipe dream on Tuesday the
industry research and energy committee
will vote to push for an integrated
energy market and also for the
diversification of supply thereby
boosting security and that's all we have
this agenda take care and enjoy the week